because if we have another guest coming
in right now okay shout out to the water
Mexican first of all shout out to water
Mexicans but second of all we have
another guest coming in right now listen
we had to sit down and talk with this
gentleman because we have a theory that
I don't know if it's possible to test
but the speed that this man possesses
the speed that this man possesses is is
not how do I say it it's not well it's
humanly possible it's human yeah yeah
but it is also like on some Lord of the
Rings [ __ ] yeah yeah like there's Beyond
human it's beyond human mystical in a
way literally that's the best way yeah
it is Mystical levels of speed bro and
I'm hoping that we could display it
right here today I don't know if we have
a backpack or something but right now we
have to bring out the [ __ ]
champ Al Joe Sterling
[Applause]
[Music]
know about this [ __ ]
okay we're watching I'm obviously
watching this fight right and I've
obviously seen you fight before but I'm
watching this one specifically and I'm
like God damn how terrifying it would be
to be in a fight with somebody right but
like a bar fight
and you think it's going to be like
straight up and then all of a sudden
they're on your back like attached to
you yeah with the speed of only a dwarf
possesses right have you been like
sparring with people and they were like
God damn bro that was some dwarf ass
[ __ ] is one of your trainers a small
person it has to be right it has to be
I mean dwarves are fast with specific
things they're not fast walking down the
street they look quite slow walking down
the street with them big old asses
bro they got the Lupita
especially
right but you possess that [ __ ] speed
bro it's uh
we worked on that a little bit we worked
on that a little bit it's a I don't know
I don't know where it came from I think
maybe wrestling yeah because you started
out wrestling yeah so the Jiu Jitsu is
newer to you it's more on you but then
it just kind of like played into the
wrestling aspect because in wrestling
and folk style like American wrestling
where you take people down you get your
points or you start in the top or bottom
position and from there I was always
like a leg Rider so the same thing like
Jiu Jitsu you throw the legs and you
take it back and try to strangle
[ __ ] try to put them to sleep
and it's kind of just easy transition so
that transition was easy very very easy
and and do you think like
like I'm specifically thinking about
even yawn fight
you're in there like at a certain point
do you go oh I can take that whenever I
want oh yeah and then Supreme confidence
after that it was you know I even I even
said like to the fans because I do I I
do like a little breakdown on my podcast
or whatever yeah and then um shout out
to pod though shout out the pot I don't
know who am I talking to the weekly
scraps thank you scratch baby
um all streaming platforms so I was
talking about it and I I break down the
fight and I go back to that fourth round
I just took his back the second round
shut him down the third round and then
the fourth round I take them down again
and I'm like I get a little cocky I'm
like I'm about to get fancy I try to
jump on his back so I get some style
points and then I fell off and I ended
up on bottom I was like all right that
was stupid but yeah yeah so pretty much
like I got confident but then at the
same time you gotta you got to still be
smart about how you're approaching it
because then just trying to jump on the
guys back no shirt on you start sweating
and then you just slide right off the
top yeah
yeah all right so you you become The
champ is there an immediate sense of
supreme confidence
not really because the way I won the
belt obviously wasn't like ideal yeah
yeah DQ got me in the head I'm like I
felt like I lost I felt like oh I'm
saying when you want when you beat uh in
the rematch oh yeah it just kind of felt
like after 13 months of people talking
[ __ ] for so long like now what
[ __ ] bow down to the king you
know you say whatever you want you can
say oh you got Rob the mic it's not a
robin if it's a close fight it's not a
robbery yeah right it's a close fight
yeah so
um that's how I felt got to shut
everybody up because they said he was
going to dominate me any way that he
wanted I'm like what am I just chopped
livers like yeah like am I not gonna
poop a fight am I in prison right now
yeah but I'm glad I went out there got
the dub and uh shut everybody up yeah
yeah and then now obviously another
dominant performance
I heard about obviously the dislocations
and that kind of stuff but I don't know
and I have a lot of respect for him but
I I just don't know if it would have
been any different I don't think I think
you're operating on a different level
right now man yeah I mean that the uh I
just the frequency felt different and um
Define that but what do you mean by
frequency like when I grabbed him and he
threw that kick it felt like everything
was in such slow motion just because we
drilled everything that he does so often
and we knew he's gonna throw the front
kick sometimes when he's in space he'll
do this stupid thing and he'll just
blast the front kick time to perfectly
caught it I was like this is just like
taking candy from a baby right now as
soon as I grabbed his leg I feel like I
felt like it was a man versus child and
I just kind of just threw him down he
just felt like I I'm not even trying to
talk [ __ ] it'll be cocky about it I feel
like when I grasped the best way to talk
[ __ ]
it felt like you were a child
foreign
this is the king That was supposed to
like what are we talking about what kind
of feather I know
we're talking about you know but yeah I
felt like it was just different levels I
mean I know the show that came out I had
a torn labor before and I had seven Pro
fights with the torn label I'm coming
down and training the same exact [ __ ] so
I'm just like don't make the excuse
about the [ __ ] about the shoulder after
you just said you won two fights against
a tough dude with the exact same [ __ ]
with the stack same [ __ ] you use it to
brag but now you use it as a crunch
because you lost like don't do that bro
don't do that don't try to hit some salt
for your wounds and go home
so what's next for you like I know
you've seen the other fights out there
like what are you what are you looking
at who is who is the the fight that you
actually think is easiest that other
people are excited for that that's
easiest I feel like this is a layup who
is it
I'm gonna slam it home Mr sugar tits I
think wow
because his grappling is like
if I'm comparing him to the three guys
that they're talking about yeah it's him
it's Cheeto is Henry sayudo yeah his
grappling I think is the least
threatening but he would probably agree
with that I'm sure he would but because
the most threatening exactly and you
don't think that he has the grappling to
get you off like if you go dwarf on him
fast forward if you go dwarf on him
there's no way that you're gonna get off
of him you're gonna ride that back yeah
baby no I I yeah I don't think I don't
think you better stop me once I got to
that position I don't think anyone in
the bandwid division honestly even if I
went went up to 45 I think I'm curious
about that like I'm 170 pounds right now
really yeah I get pretty big man people
think it's like oh you took no damage
just go back and fight another
another couple months like can I eat a
little bit I want to chill yeah and just
bounce back up and do that [ __ ] all over
again this [ __ ] hurts yeah but people
don't understand unless you've been
through the trenches a little bit you're
170 right now right now I fight at 135
sure holy [ __ ] that is not it's not fun
yeah what is the cut
um see dove that's what you should do
well the last the last week I do about
like 10 pounds so it's not not actually
crazy it's like 12 the last week but I
have to ink like do it in increments to
slowly get down so the week before I'm
walking around about 50 to 55 and then
from there
I skipped the water low going and then
that last week on Sunday I'm hoping to
wake up at like 1 48 147 and then I go
into Tuesday fight week which is the
official fight week and maybe like 147
146 yeah and then from there I got to
just maintain that it's like super low
energy and I'm already I'm already lean
man yeah so to find 35. that's why it's
surprising it's not easy you know so I
gotta it hurts man so that's the best
way I could put it people are going to
say why don't you just go up away I'm
like I would but then I got to fight
these guys who are six two six four like
those are monsters because they're
dropping down from 190 probably yeah
some of them yeah we have some guys that
walk around like a buck 80 and they cut
down so it's like a 10 pound Gap yeah
but that 10 pounds makes a big
difference when you're trying to take
somebody down or when they're cracking
you in the face what's that cheap meal
after you've been cutting weight what do
you come back with last night drunk last
night drunk eating some 99 pizza slices
yeah working out giving a shout out to
New York Street New York uh City Pizza
yeah got a dollar slice with you guys
you guys want to hook you up
that was me just talking [ __ ] all night
yesterday
that's that piece I got y'all it's on me
baby 100 bucks make everyone's day but
um I'll eat anything but I love Jamaican
food man oh yeah I always go to the
Jamaican food some some oxtails yeah
yeah I know you guys had big big act
yeah
he's funny as hell
it's hilarious where's Big October yo is
out in Wisconsin bro yeah he's got his
shows this weekend yeah he had to go to
it what part of New York do you say
you're from Long Island Long Island okay
I was actually gonna guess that I was
like we're like the sixth Borough you
know yeah
we're jumping that Dwarf House
nah you blink he's on your back I swear
to God but yeah it's like it's all right
you're from Far Rock yeah
if you got sand you're from Long Island
say that to people from all right well
no I want to exactly
[Music]
exactly that yeah well he actually grew
up near there too he grew up on Fire
Island that's a fact
parents thought you were ugly bro why
are you crazy because they took little
old you 12 years old to the island let
you unsupervised let you run around yeah
but what's wrong with that what you
think he's just a [ __ ] little boys
bro I'm just saying why would you put
that on there it's not the church
for my life
okay so what are you thinking this
weekend who do you got
that's a tough one man but because I'm
I'm in the game like you go from someone
every not even someone like the world
doubt on you you know what I mean yeah
and saying that you have no chance of
winning this fight and you're just like
okay yeah we'll see and then you got
this fight where I'm just like Izzy
versus I think Izzy's gonna he should
win
but that man's got that old Lefty man
that [ __ ] just when that [ __ ] smacks you
that [ __ ] is just yeah he put him down
with that before once before before
right so yeah there's always that
punchest chance but I do think he's a
little too slow for a guy like Izzy yeah
and he should be able to pick him apart
if he's smart I know he's talking this
entertainment [ __ ] again if he's doing
that it could get him caught get them
clapped yeah but I think if he fights
tomorrow the same way he did against Ken
and air and uh yo well Romero it might
have been boring right not the most
entertaining but yeah smart it was
technical but isn't it the job of the
person who's challenged challenges
exactly let the Challenger go take that
belt you wanted it exactly don't [ __ ]
start criticizing me because your boy
came in here and didn't do enough to win
not me 100 yeah because I'm a fair
criticism obviously it's fight sports
right we want to have we want to have
the most exciting fights yeah 100 that's
what we want and you and as a fighter
you also want to have the most exciting
fights because that's how you're going
to make the most money yes you I'm sure
you're going in there going I hope I get
a highlight real finish in some way oh
yeah because that's what people want to
see absolutely they want to see that's
what they tune into and will you know
that will you put yourself in more
danger you think knowing that yeah
really do because you got to go for it
so you got to take chances well you can
sit there and point fighting and be
smart and look at it like a sparring
session but if you want to go out there
and get these highlights man you got to
take risks man and my coach always says
Ray Longo always goes
to in order to knock somebody out you
got to be in a position to to get
knocked out you know what I mean yo and
that's that I mean I was like okay and
that's that's a good way you're looting
yourself in the dangers yeah because
most of us the same size same frame if I
throw a punch out you could probably hit
me maybe it's a different angle I'm
slipping the punch while you throw
something I missed but I hit you but if
I throw something and I miscalculate
that and you clap me exposed that's yeah
so going for it especially with those
little gloves is not boxing man you
don't got these pillows to protect you a
little bit yeah so yeah it's a different
game man you you hit somebody with one
of these that that's night night yeah
have you have you felt
have you felt like a a just an emotional
difference from other people now that
you're champ oh yeah especially the love
is on my back I still get booed and I
take it all in I'm like yeah yeah yeah
bring it bring it but it doesn't look
like people are riding for you now ah
I feel both and you know what it is you
know I kind of feel [ __ ] up about this
because I'm a little
they got me on the fence now because
I feel like before I had a lot of love
when I finished Corey CNA again that was
in 2020 and everyone was calling me the
uncrown champ yeah and then I go into
this title fight the UFC does everything
they can to not give me this title fight
why do you think I don't know because I
really don't know
Marlo moresi knocked me out that was
2017. I'm like dude we're way past that
yeah I'm in a different spot he lost the
title shot yeah and he's trying to
battle back now he's fighting Corey
sandhagen if Marlon Mirage beats Dan
Hagin Marlon Morris LeapFrogs me to get
another shot of the title and I get
pushed down to the bottom he loses his
course in how he beats him I slept Corey
San Diego in the first round okay so
then they try Frank Yeager he fights
Pedro Munoz he has a split decision win
very back and forth
um close fight so now Frankie egg is not
not the hero that they thought he was
going to be coming down so now it's back
to algebraic Sterling so whatever I get
the title shot
now people that never see me fight they
only seen that fight so now they have
this burnt image in the head like this
guy sucks and I get it I'm like I've
only seen that fight I'd be like okay
this guy's not very very good so I've
always been very in tune with the fans I
always interact with fans they talk [ __ ]
I talk [ __ ] back they think it's like an
insecurity thing like dude I really
don't give a [ __ ] I write it and I go
and that's it yeah but I like to engage
yeah so then going back to what you're
saying
um I feel like after that young fight
how everyone just flipped on me and
it was like a different emotion that I
got because now I'm one you're saying
yeah so now I feel a little bit colder
to them because I'm just like because
people thought that you were lying about
it or you weren't doing it yeah yeah it
was that
um one one was that saying I was acting
and uh
just like how they wrote me off they
were I was once a fan I'm like
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] why do
you feel compelled that you need to go
out of your way to write that yeah
that's a wild card that's like I was
once offend but then after your antics
I'm like Antics I got [ __ ] needs in
the headboard
what are we talking about oh yeah but
you sold it I'm like I sold it I'm like
dude I'm exhausted yeah I got blasted in
my head I've been getting punched the
entire time yeah I took my ass whooping
like a man I'm like what do you want me
to do like I don't know how you can act
that in that moment in time like dude I
had no recollection of that night until
I got back to the um back to the uh the
house yeah so it is what it is I just
felt like now after I beat y'all not
everyone wants to take a picture and
everything I'm just like oh so [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you you're cool
that's how I really felt I'm just like
man I can't be it's hard to trust the
support yeah because now I'm like no I
see you I don't know if you want to run
up on me because you lost some money on
the DQ on the DQ um win uh so now I
don't I don't I just don't know how to
feel because I'm like I don't know if
you're a real one or you're you're just
sitting here and it just makes me look
at the interactions a little bit
different I kind of try to distance
myself now unless I feel like I don't
say safe but you just don't know what
people's intentions are man so New York
yes
people are just like we don't trust
kindness here yeah because kindness is
usually used to take money out of our
pockets exactly and not in this way a
bad way but it's like if somebody comes
up in the street and they're like hey
man how you doing like you have a moment
yeah you're like oh because it's a
moment for for what exactly like can I
save the trees or whatever are you
trying to get some money so yeah yeah
but at the same time what is that saying
like uh profits let people convert now
I'm not saying you've got to be a
prophet but if you are going to be
someone that people are fans of you're
gonna have to let them be won over by
you and you've given performances that
are worth getting one over right like
yeah I so that's one of those things
where like and I know it takes time I
went through the same [ __ ] I remember
when I was when I was doing the MTV
shows and people would notice me on the
street but I didn't know that they were
looking at me for that yes
I'm gonna do nothing but I'm from New
York so I'm a fake do something you know
[Laughter]
I'm looking at them
and sometimes you're just like that like
I grew up very different so people that
don't understand like they looking at me
I'm just staring at [ __ ] I'm just like I
don't know what yeah what's going on
through your head but you staring at me
and making me uncomfortable but they're
standing too like that dwarf
[ __ ]
you know how fast he is
they're intimidated by you they don't
want to interrupt your day they've seen
you watch they paid 60 to watch you
fight and you're still coming off of
this thing like do people like me do
they not like that it will take a second
it will go away but let that [ __ ] go bro
I try man I try because I again I just I
don't know like my upbringing my brother
was blood
um there's a lot of gang violence
growing up in my in uh in unit of
Roosevelt where I grew up in and um it's
just it's just different so you kind of
have to be a little bit on edge a little
bit because you're not getting involved
in that
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
there's a friend of mine there's a
friend up there that you guys all know
and uh I remember we were in high school
and he was you know he was hanging up
town he was hanging with some blood
dudes and whatever and uh he was like
yeah they really want me to join and I
was like oh what is that into and uh he
goes well you know they want me to like
cut somebody's face with a box cutter
and I'm like
let's see it's like quite the commitment
you guys can't just be friends I don't
really work like that like okay yeah but
that's what it is right like it could be
intense but yeah I'm just glad I never
fully committed into it you know because
I found wrestling Russell gave me a
different direction different path but
yeah I dabbled a little bit I saw a
couple fight one dude swung a bike with
the pegs on it the puppies whoa and swag
is doing it this is outside of the
school though he used anything and I was
just like anything I'm thinking I'm like
yeah this I'm like five foot three I'm
maybe a hundred and ten pounds I'm like
yeah this life ain't for me I'm gonna go
play basketball let me get my bike back
and I'm gonna leave
I was like I'm Gonna Leave This one
alone was it older brother or younger
brother older brother now did he in any
way do like he see your success with
wrestling and go yo why don't you try to
ride that to something Russell was gay
considered gay
the black people didn't wrestle
you have to be like one of the only
people exactly like straight up like we
we did have a really good wrestling team
but yeah I didn't come out with the team
for years and I was just like give your
brother credit if you're doing this
directly no he said that [ __ ] was wild
fish
that's the only way white people can be
greater than sport is that black people
think it's gay
all right guys we gotta take a break for
a second because it's time to get
healthy okay we're gonna get healthy the
quick and easy way with one delicious
scoop of athletic greens one AG one
right here you're absorbing 75 high
quality vitamins minerals Whole Food
Source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to help start your day right
okay this special blend of ingredients
supports your gut health your nervous
system your immune system your energy
recovery focus and aging all the things
literally okay ag1 is a small micro
habit with massive benefits you're going
to be sleeping better the quality is
going to be so improved of your recovery
specifically the mental Clarity and
alertness you're gonna get and it costs
you less than three dollars a day you're
investing in your health and it's
cheaper than your cold brew habit think
about that right now
it's time to reclaim your health and arm
your immune system with convenient daily
nutrition it's just one scoop in a cup
of water every day that's it no need for
a million different pills and
supplements look out for your health to
make it easy athletic greens is going to
give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com flagrant again that
is athleticgreens.com flagrant to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
now let's get back to the show so then
why'd you why why'd you go do it well I
got cut from the basketball team right
and then after that I realized like I'm
gonna be five for four the coach the
wrestling coach came up to me he's like
you're gonna be nothing but five foot
four 115 pounds soaking wet just come
Russell if you don't like it then I
won't ever bother you again you try to
get me ninth grade my best friend tried
to get me in ninth grade try to get me
the seventh and I was like nah dude like
just this guy's gonna be singlets
they're touching each other like the
Jamaicans we never I've never seen this
a day in my life I'm like yo bro what
the [ __ ] I'm daggering with men
they like crouching
all this [ __ ] I'm like do you see these
guys they circling you're like
crazy
that's not for me
wow you first day of wrestling yo
imagine getting your brother to come to
the tournament
I think they might have came to like two
matches man the entire High School
career really that's it crazy right yeah
but now they like make with like hey
yeah
that's why he became so great though
because you're like I can't lose to this
guy that's you know dude well yeah yeah
but yeah I'm just glad I found that gave
me a different avenue different so what
convinced you to do it uh well I got cut
that was literally so then after that
they pull you and then you go fine I'll
give it a try like yeah so I came down
to the practice I was like what do I
need and then it was like it came down
we it was like a WWE match there was
like no real rules like he didn't teach
us the rules like that he made it fun so
he didn't like go like you got to be in
the stands and doing all this boring
[ __ ] we came down it was like a battle
royale it's like you just gotta take
them down and swim on the floor it's
like
so for me it's like oh we're about to
body up yeah and like are you sure you
definitely know you guys all know you
know you're in the whole way you
wrestling you're grabbing each other's
pants down pick somebody up and you know
you're trying to we call it back then
I'm trying to irf you you know yeah it's
a little bit different so that's what
we're doing so now when the obviously
you can't do that in like a real
wrestling match grabbing a singlet yeah
but that's what I'm doing I'm trying to
like yoke them up real quick yeah slam
them down and I'm like all right this is
this is kind of fun yeah and from there
I was I was hooked man then they started
learning the rules I'm like all right
this is a little bit more complicated
yeah and then my first match I got my
ass whipped I got attacked tech means
you got beat by 15 points or more I have
no idea what was going I thought it was
in this match the whole time
I have no idea because at the end
raising his hand she's like that was me
that was me
oh my God he was just biting you by the
rules no idea the points he was turning
me I'm like flipping around like trying
to get up yeah I stand up I'm like and I
get taken down again I'm like I thought
I gave him everything I got but I lost
the match and then they blew the whistle
and I'm like what happened what happened
no your match is over like what do you
mean so I'm just confused he's like yeah
you got attacked I'm like what does that
mean he's like if coach just looks over
like yeah you got you got words
I'm like damn I didn't know crazy okay
so what made you go back after that I
would have been like that that's my
first match it was a varsity match too
and I'm I should have been on the uh
yeah what do you call it the uh JV yeah
yeah but I guess they threw me in there
because you know I'm scrapping with the
big dogs in there but I don't know the
rules I'm just scrapping so I guess he
like just took a chance but I got my ass
I was one and done that day so I lost
that Mansion I was just chilling for the
rest of the day which kind of sucked
yeah wrestling tournaments they're kind
of shitty in that regards like if you
lose you literally we go all into the
barbecue so you lose you just done for
the day done you just watch everybody
else wrestle eat food and just be bored
all day they got to change the uniforms
that's how they get more people you know
they got like the shorts now and like
this the um the rash guard to make it
more like a oh it's not like a gladiator
that's kind of cool they can still wear
the one the onesie the one the singer
it's the one piece by cute I mean my
wrestling Community
before you go out there it's just a
little
yeah to be intimidating you know Connor
always goes out there with a big old
[ __ ] rock hard
you know it kind of blue twos before you
gotta hit a Bluetooth
when he was doing a Face-Off with
Mayweather he didn't see that well he
put those pictures and I'm like dude
what are you doing like I think you know
what you're doing but why are you doing
this everybody to see yeah would you not
be intimidated by that you go on a
Face-Off you feel them
Joker Irish dick you don't think
you touch noses and tips that's a little
intimidating bro you're like why do I
feel you before I feel you yeah that's
crazy
who do you think I'm hoping in Somali
but I'm hearing Rumblers and usually
when you hit a Rumblings it's true it's
gonna be Henry the only thing about
Henry I don't mind fighting him he has a
four in three years so I go out there
and I spank this [ __ ] right then
you're gonna go oh you beat a guy who's
on the couch for three years I'm like
there's no winning there's no way why do
you think why would it be Henry I don't
know is there like big interest in
seeing him fight again
oh no I gotta actually you'll see that
because I'm just like dude the money
fight is the guy with the colorful hair
yeah give me that [ __ ] give me
six nine yeah yeah
and what is strategy for that for which
one six nine yeah
because I just realized I'm still
calling him close the gap man he fights
well going backwards though that guy can
he could spark you going backwards which
is dangerous but once I close that
window I think I locked my hands around
his waist pause I think I get a body
lock I can literally fold him up during
the fight
you take that back he's like yo pause
yeah I'm sorry okay I'm gonna be on this
back three minutes
the ref gets you up and you're like yeah
you were right I was on his back that
was a little while the dominated
position you know pause on that too
that's great so so what happens you
close that distance and then you
that's what he's just gonna do that's
what they all do they give up their bag
and they just Dominate and why
why do they give up everybody
why do they give up their back I think
they I don't know I feel like
I feel like on a serious note I feel
like they're trying to
they think that's the better way to get
out but which is for wrestling you you
go you give the back in order to escape
you go two and one fight the hands you
you um peel and turn and face you get
one point Escape
for this you give your bag you get taken
down I throw the hooks in I'm looking to
choke you out or if you do what TJ did
and then you allow me to get to a
mountain position you get you're gonna
get [ __ ] up yeah so you got to pick
your poison in which one you want to be
in you know so I think for them they
think the best route is to escape is to
turn you back but when they do that I
think they underestimate how good my
control actually is and that's not me
once you get your legs around them
that's what I always thought with you
when I was watching it's like once you
get those legs wrapped around them it's
like they're there until you allow them
to not be yeah or without no rings or
the Bell Rings yeah I mean it was crazy
to see the control well TJ was saying he
got out with one arm and trying to give
himself props I'm like you know you got
out because I was beating your ass right
that's why you got up yeah if I wasn't
beating your ass you'd have been there I
could have I could have held you there
until this day you're still being Abu
Dhabi on the floor
what are you talking about
bro
[Music]
that [ __ ] had me crying it was good huh
yeah do you know how to get sturdy uh
absolutely 30 baby okay so if the track
comes on you can get started I will get
sturdy so this is some
it's an R B song
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
he helped me out a little bit because I
need a little Direction but I got a
decent floor okay decent floor it's not
gonna be like oh this guy should just
stick the frame my man what I hope it's
not like that what is the what you guys
can rip me apart I don't give a [ __ ]
what is this song my job my job is to
fight hopefully this is like decent yeah
I think it's I think it is my brother
got some buzz on it wait so it's you and
your brother me and my brother yeah my
younger brother yeah we both wrestle we
wrestled in college together okay okay
wait a minute your older brother also
wrestled no no my younger brother how
many of you are I got like 22 siblings
bro wait we got an army we got a
football team
you got a league what are you talking
about
you know he goes yeah my brother
wrestling and I go wait you're older
brother he goes man I got 22 siblings
bro yeah
my mom has 10 kids and then the rest are
like all halves yeah
so yeah it's deep 10 children yeah
you're not sticky I guess yeah
do you have any kids no not yet not yet
I hope I'm hoping you know you don't
have any yeah
go to the beginning
all right World premiere what is it
got some Spanish
for yourself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
okay okay I did drop a backpack line in
there too what'd you say I said I don't
even know what that's what I said
come on I think I said something like
turning around introduce it to the
backpack
[Music]
oh that's fine You Gotta Throw dwarf
speed in a bar bro dwarf speed is a
crazy bar bro we just got a donation
Mark please don't ever do that again
[ __ ] gave you two dollars to
never dance again you know how long he's
been working on
she's a Scottish woman romance
you all don't know how to dance bro that
was Riverdance bro
[Music]
it's the East River Dance that's how we
dance over on the East River bro that's
how it is that [ __ ] was a little
different what's the name of the song
son just please oh no we don't really
have a name you need a name for that
pool deck I think it's gonna be like as
stupid though because it's just like a
little we're coming for Bad Bunny baby
you come for Bad Bunny you coming from
the spot we come for that spot yeah that
Bunny's lit no that [ __ ] on top
of the world I don't know a single song
you go to a show you know not yet all
right shows have you been for now I
don't know what the [ __ ] he was saying
but I was in there like Shorty's going
crazy or what yeah it was it was it was
a good time man oh yeah you got a girl I
forgot you got it yeah yeah how long you
guys been together 11 years she looked
at the DMS
ah no she doesn't look at them blue
check he's coming through now well it's
mostly dudes man
this is crazy yeah that's a Jamaican man
right there that was good why all these
dudes in my DMs I don't know what I'm
saying yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah she
thinks she thinks it's the opposite but
I'm like I mean I wish that'd be nice
but unfortunately it's not like that he
was out
you were out clean
now you gotta deal with what do you mean
you wish no I'm just saying it would be
nice to just not have a bunch of dudes
coming to you yeah yeah you want some
female attention as well a little bit
yeah it's like Aisha I mean I have to go
down that path
curry curry oh really you like her no no
I'm saying like her whole situation I
just want the attention
yeah that was wild that she did that no
that was really crazy I would never do
that yeah if our girls won that that
would be crazy but I get it though get
it like you just want to have the
acknowledgment now but after it starts
that's where it starts that's where it
starts don't let that [ __ ] happen you're
right that's a that's a cancer don't let
that cancer disrespectful what what what
imagine your girl comes home I just want
the attention we talk about stuff yeah
but how much attention we're talking
about yeah how much attention are we
talking about just like now like hey how
you doing you look beautiful today I'm
like I'm not going to beat somebody up
because of that no but if it starts like
you know what if it starts if they're
talking about cheeks or something like
that yeah that's different it's a whole
different whole disrespect yeah there's
a whole different but you can't beat
people up no more no you do it for a
living I can just invite them to the gym
and then uh do a dance off it would do
whatever you know wait if you went into
a fight in public you get in trouble I
would imagine that but if it's like
self-defense I'll be right oh okay yeah
so it's not like that boxing rule where
it's like uh yeah we're licensed like in
like each commission that we fight for
we gotta like apply for a license to
compete that's about it like this like
over my hands the license I used to hear
people say that [ __ ] like what the [ __ ]
does that even mean bro but you apply
for a license that's as far as it goes
as far as I know but you can't get like
punished more because you're a
professional fighter I probably would
get the book thrown at me oh because I
know how I know what I'm doing yeah my
man this guy watch YouTube videos you
know what he's doing too no no no he
watched YouTube videos that he did not
know yeah
one more time her name is Deborah her
name is
when he was doing this one when he was
like
yeah yeah dude that's how you do it
you're doing great you're doing good job
that's how you do it
[Music]
okay okay
and you know what
it's trying to be funny this is way
better
when he was when he was trying it was
horrible that was actually kind of fun
come on come on come on ready all right
we're ready
you know what I said he's like oh
yeah
this is so hard because the song is on
beat and I'm not like if it was off like
I could dance better
counting out is disrespectful yeah why
would you count you know what it is for
me today I thought it was the end of the
round this is what it is
three and four and jump he's on beat
when he goes down his knees want to give
up yeah he can't catch the feet how do
these kids do that dude those gears I
see the knees yes no when I'm when I'm
here I'm a great dancer when I'm here
I'm strong yeah yeah I don't go down
there I've got all these strong levels
oh no bro what is that by the way what
is this yeah is that water yeah
baby we got my Hennessy yeah let's get
that boy Big Hawk yeah
big actor prize bro what you making two
we did we did a little show thing on
complex a little while help them out
with his fashion because you you good
why was Al killing act for his fashion
oh yo bro
you saw it though where'd you go with
the space what what sneakers the
sneakers were crazy I don't know why he
wore them yeah the megatrons are crazy
bro they gave him like two two three
inches though right oh yeah yeah yeah
which that I respect but you could do
that in a better way yeah yeah that
those sneakers you'll never see them
again did you ever go for that owl
always does the lifts he does the lips
get like extra inch I don't wear no
platforms
[Music]
well we're partners with it which one
the Sundays yeah I'll try that you want
a tequila or do you want to stay on a
brown I'm good with whatever I'll try to
uh your [ __ ] all right bet yeah yo thank
you for being so helpful for some love
man you know what I'm saying yeah this
is a coconut [ __ ] right here you're
Jamaican you're gonna like that some rum
right now trying to like build some
connections in Jamaica and do some rum
yeah like I want to have them like
actually produce it and distill it down
there and all that
just to like keep it with the culture
you know yeah it's gonna pull you up but
that's good it's a business man
I'm trying man this you know the
fighting [ __ ] is only yeah such a short
yeah rear window I know Usman black
panther forever yeah yeah
I like that have you seen it yet the
movie no no oh I'm trying to go with my
sisters like probably like
10 of us so you have to rent out the
yeah yeah how many theaters you got to
get for your whole family I don't know
there's gonna be a bunch of us though so
I'm hoping it's uh it's a good time yeah
yeah that's wild 22.
siblings
I feel like you guys are waiting for the
review right now oh yeah yeah you took
us today we got a step going yeah what
are we thinking that's the coconut
Tequila
you know for not being cold it's
actually pretty smooth that all right
all right I think that's a problem
no that is good that's what you want
yeah you want it to be smooth because
we're quick to call something trash so
that's a cop you know I used to think
I'm never gonna slowly these guys
I used to think Patron was like high-end
but that [ __ ] yeah that [ __ ] ain't it no
no no no you need that [ __ ] classes
Class A uh I'd [ __ ] with Julio
um
it's good but it's it's like it's good
no I'm not even gonna do it yeah
it's good The Rock listen we live the
rock
love your tequila I love you so
delicious that's amazing son I'm curious
absolutely I want to know about to come
up what's the first dumb thing you
bought after you got money after I got
money [ __ ] man you know if I had beat
that [ __ ] brand Caraway I was
gonna buy a jet ski that would have been
the dummy so I would have thought I was
rich I was like I'm gonna finish him in
the first round I'm gonna take the 50
G's and by [ __ ] jet ski and I lost
but it's like I have my paycheck I
didn't get a bonus what I make like for
that fight I think I made like
26 000 or 30 000 just to show how much
you got to pay the uh trainers and those
guys
um usually both my coaches would take
five percent I think now is a little
different because now the paycheck's a
lot higher so you know kind of five
percent they take each five percent yeah
so that would work out the 10 and then
management would be ten which I'm in the
process of finding new management right
now oh really yeah the whole
managers but the management game in this
space is like almost criminal to me
because you negotiate it one time
contract right
and then we fight constantly so you get
paid to do something one time and you
get a you get a standard contract
where it's just like well you got us a
standard contract so how much was that
actually worth yeah like why not just
pay you a one-time fee or pay you a much
lower percentage if you're not going to
actually manage my career in terms of
helping to build my brand and if you
have
50 60 some of these guys 75 just to
clarify what you're saying is when you
sign the contract with the UFC you're
signing for an amount per fight
is that what you're saying so so why
does the manager need to get paid every
single time when the fee is already
decided for every fight yes so you're
not negotiating anything if you are
negotiating every single fight like a
lot of times with you in boxing Etc you
need a manager to go to war every single
day
I thought you guys negotiate every
single fight that's what they're always
talking about oh we wait until the
paperwork sign before no no I think
that's just a lot it's different and I
try like I'm always getting Flack for
this from the fans because they like oh
you don't why you talk about the the
contracts and [ __ ] I'm like because it's
a very [ __ ] important part of what we
do bro yeah like I put food on the table
with what we do yeah so the contract is
very important so where I'm very I'm one
of the smarter Fighters I I give myself
credit for that and I learned from
people making their mistakes and not
doing things the right way paying your
taxes like [ __ ] like that like little
things like that write-offs and things
like that having a business and knowing
where you can not cut corners but do
things on the up and up yeah and find
those loopholes that you know people
were like pissed at Donald Trump yeah
they get rid of that G-Wagon [ __ ] yeah
are they really you heard about the
whole right off the yeah getting rid of
it isn't that crazy enough people once
it comes up on Tick Tock they [ __ ]
get ready I'm the reason
you said it I changed the tax code that
sure was listening also the G wagon
after people found out that should
skyrocketed all right bro price for a
g-rack G-Wagon even a used one I
apologize I apologize why are you even
getting a G wagon though you could get
so many different other like cars that
could be way better in my opinion what's
the dream car
you know I want that Adventure door man
I read that I wrote that [ __ ] one time I
was like oh I fell in love if you don't
live in New York anymore then no I'm in
Vegas oh okay oh you're living full time
because I thought you were training here
a lot too I do training okay but I split
my time I got a house in Vegas that's my
primary residence and I got a house in
New York that's my
my secondary home you know right for tax
purposes but tax purposes yeah no so I
spent yeah I spent more than half a year
in Vegas of course you do I do
everything on the up and up yeah so
Uncle Sam doesn't come trying to knock
out my door yeah yeah you want to take
extra but that's what I'm saying like
these Fighters need to like look into
things like that to be smart yeah to
like when I first got to UFC I made
eight thousand and eight thousand so
eight thousand what that meant yeah
eight thousand show up just to get into
the cage another eight thousand to win
okay now you factor into five percent
the ten percent
um that money goes like that now you're
talking about expenses yeah now you're
talking about just to get to the fight
now you're talking about food what you
need anyway but people think like oh you
live in the dream like yeah but we're
Chasing the Dream yeah just like
everybody else in everyday life you're
chasing the American dream right so it
takes a little bit of time so I tried to
explain this to like the younger guys
that I coach or like [ __ ] with like from
the team like I always try to share the
knowledge to the to the Next Generation
so that they could be on game because no
one really did that for me but I would
do my research I would learn from people
if like just by overhearing them talk
and things like that if I could jump
into a room with people smarter than me
and I try to take advantage of that
wherever I can and you never know
everything you know so a guy come from
unidel trust me they ain't teaching me
none of this [ __ ] so I had to learn me
neither exactly so yeah
we don't learn the [ __ ] in school so
yeah if you don't figure it out Uncle
Sam's coming for you one way or the
other you got to make sure you do the
right thing to make sure your protection
is crazy they don't bear minimum teach
you tax law and I'm not talking about
loopholes but just tax law yeah they
should teach you everything that they'll
arrest you for if you don't do it right
you know why because the majority of
people work at W-2 jobs
for the IRS Bobby we'll never know
[Laughter]
but you're right exactly most people are
having those jobs on it but still like
at least know what you're giving up I
think that's something that's really
frustrating are you going to listen to
school though be honest no I won't win a
tax collector I won't but I still know
how to do math yeah some stuff some
stuff will stay you know what I mean
yeah like I still remember a few things
from school even if I don't know how to
do my taxes the fact that the fact that
the the education system at least put it
out there now it's on me if I [ __ ] my
taxes up yeah yeah now I don't have to
feel like I'm kind of duped there's a
system that's out there that don't
understand it's intimidating to learn
about so I'm just gonna hire somebody to
do it God knows what the [ __ ] they're
doing so yeah I think that's unfair yeah
because everything else does don't you
don't even fed Health ever like all the
things bro but I mean we should why
because yeah safety they don't teach you
how to stroke they teach you like how to
put on condoms yeah safety some of them
teachers
what happened to you bro one of my
teachers almost caught some Strokes bro
you're a victim I almost did I almost
did become a victim how cute was that
guy he was real he was throwing it back
yeah
it gets dirty he's getting used dirty he
got me super sturdy you know he got me
yeah no I feel like you got to teach
that kind of [ __ ] you got your head on
your shoulders man yeah try it man
that's why I'm like I'm looking into
Ventures like this to Branch out because
fighting short window man got to make
sure you're doing the right thing
protecting yourself and then we even
like taxes 40 30 like you got to make
sure like you set aside that yeah
because they don't do that for you they
just give you all that money at once and
that's good luck that's it thanks for
coming and uh you got to make sure you
budget everything out so you got to take
care of family members
I help out you help out I'll just leave
it at that yeah yeah because people get
offended that's stressful too though
right like I'm not saying that you can't
actually even me saying that might me
saying that my siblings and what sibling
knows that he's helping and the other
one's like wait a minute [ __ ] come on
you gotta be like yo you my half brother
like
you get a half
yeah but the same thing I try to guide
them gives them the knowledge but
sometimes I know they feel like I'm
always preaching to them yeah so no one
wants the preacher nobody wants to hear
[ __ ] until you make real money and then
they want to hear everything yeah yeah
once like when rich people talk
everybody shuts the [ __ ] up Elon can say
whatever the [ __ ] he wants about any
goddamn thing he's like yo let's let's
drill holes in the ground we're like all
right all right that sounds interesting
you know what I mean once you make that
real [ __ ] money because money is the
hardest thing for most people to make
when you think about it it's getting
harder and the more you get the more
they're gonna listen
yeah it's it's a catch 22. you think
like sometimes they listen sometimes
it's resentful and I'm not listening
that's true like I speak to a few of my
dudes back in for a rocket so they don't
want to hear nothing none of that [ __ ]
wow oh they think they know yeah that's
the worst part when you think you know
I'm just like I guess I'm just I ain't
doing [ __ ] they're like yeah
I'm an idiot yeah
yeah so let's say like fighting wise
down in the next like five ten years
whatever what do you think that next
venture would be like would it be
related to fighting or do you think it'd
be something totally different they're
like yo I want to get into this industry
well I would like to open up a full-on
social media company for
um or I guess Media company for MMA yeah
like really get into that space giving
like Fighters the platform to elevate
their profiles because I know what it's
like to be down here and not have money
to pay for a guy to do the editing and
all the stuff to help promote your fight
because that's where the money comes
from people don't know you and you got
to be willing to put the work in though
yeah a lot of people think like doing
all this is easy like oh you just go
there and you talk I'm like all right so
you've got a dog yeah pull up let's go
let's do this [ __ ] tell me how it goes
yeah you know there's a lot of work that
goes behind the scenes you know so uh I
want to do something like that I want to
have like maybe a supplement company
maybe uh hopefully a rum company and
then uh whatever else maybe I'm coaching
on the side or something like that I
don't want to be like locked into a gym
but if there's like specific Fighters
that I like yeah and they want to work
with me kind of thing I'll be willing to
have them like maybe put them up and do
their training camp maybe by the house
and be like an overseer kind of thing
like that would be fun that'll be
interesting yeah yeah I think that's
smart the way you're looking at it and
the bigger your profile gets the easier
all those things are yeah so it's like
putting that time in like even doing
something like this like doing the
podcast like being part of like being
part of the culture outside of fighting
yeah that's what really makes somebody
have that kind of celebrity moment like
when you look at the MMA stars that have
kind of broke out they're part of
culture outside of just the UFC yeah you
know like DC shout out DC he's bro he's
a monster right now DC I'm waiting for
I'm waiting on my rep share though by
the way from him okay yeah why why why
why why why talk to me I pitched them an
idea to do a sit-down clip with Henry
sayudo and he took the whole [ __ ]
thing and that [ __ ] did numbers for him
I was like bro I'm still waiting on my
we need a little bit we need a club
but he filmed this yes like two days ago
but he's [ __ ] brilliant yeah like
he's he's pretty yeah we need a little
piece of that but like also he's he's
one of those guys he's a perfect example
and like him when him and Ariel had that
show was amazing yeah because he's he's
like he's the least I don't want to say
at least defensive person meaning like
you can bust his balls and he'll laugh
along yeah like he's really jovial but
at the same time he can [ __ ] people up
yeah like he doesn't look like he could
take out most of the people on the
roster probably today
but if he wanted to how many people are
really [ __ ] DC up not many even at
his age not me right yeah it's very rare
you get somebody like that yeah it's
like have that calm I love that he loves
it yeah he loves this [ __ ] and so it's
like you can watch him just talk about
it because you can see how much his
passion is yeah yeah do you do you think
you have passion for the sport like
could you see yourself doing like
commentating on fights or like being in
that realm the color commentating like
Joe Rogan DC Bisping those guys
um that might be a little tougher I
never I've done that maybe I think three
times
but I love the sport that I watch it
every week and when I do my podcast is
called the weekly scratch yeah so I
watch the fights every week yeah so
there's always something like what's
scrapping in and MMA it's like a little
cheesy thing but that's really what it
is like the weekly scraps even if it's
not directly MMA like what happened in
the week that could be something cool to
talk about yeah you know so that's like
the idea behind that so I'm looking to
build that out and really see where we
can take it which directions but I do
think maybe I could color commentate but
I like being on the desk a little bit
just breaking down and analyzing the
fights because a lot of people don't
understand it yeah so I feel especially
with the grappling I can I can break
down the sequences from the common
everyday person to understand do you do
that digestible do you do that on for
YouTube as well and clip that out for
YouTube because you know Izzy has had
amazing success like going over fights
and putting that out the freestyle
vendor Channel have you seen his stuff
yeah okay so it's like and if you really
understand and can analyze it seems like
you do like having those clipped out
from the Pod even if you're doing them
in the podcast yeah but also like real
reacting to it and playing the video and
watching it that'd be great and for the
for like a casual kind of fan like I
mean myself I love the sport but I don't
know I don't know like I know boxing
yeah so it'd be really nice to hear
especially some of his grappling
background to teach me what it's going
what's going on in those clinches
teach me about the dwarf like you know
you're gonna take someone's back before
it happens there's a moment where you go
okay this guy's vulnerable and I'm
making that move oh yeah I don't know it
until I see it does that make sense yeah
100 and like sometimes you'll hear that
like oh he's got the double under hooks
like so in certain things I'm I'm
hearing and I go okay he has a position
where he has the advantage learning that
kind of stuff is super valuable so my
thing with that is when they post the
clips of the fights like
I know sometimes YouTube can get weird
with like oh you posted this and they
demonetize your [ __ ] and all that
craziness so it's like how much of it
can you actually post you're allowed to
react
why are your fights are once I mean
correct me if I'm wrong once the fights
are on YouTube yeah you're allowed to
react to whatever's on YouTube I'm
assuming that's the case I don't know
necessarily what the contract is the UFC
and like ESPN plus yeah it gets a little
dicey yeah but I would like to post
clips from like even in my training
camps when I show like a jiu jitsu round
like a five minute round and I break
down and I pause it and I'll go like at
this point he goes here he's reaching
for the key lock and then I noticed that
he's doing that he's applying pressure
so I alleviate the pressure by turning
around stepping around the corner
looking to step a hook in and from there
I pull him to the other side and I get
the other hook in then from there he's
still holding to the key lock I free my
arm clear the fingertips
um and then I'm looking for the choke
wow so it's like little [ __ ] like that I
would love to see that I understand it
that's the thing like yeah
but like I didn't understand what I need
is that for your fight with yawn yeah I
need that like I need to see the
sequence got you there we go yeah but do
you feel me like yeah like I need to
know at what point you knew that he
could not control the fact that you were
about to take the back at this point he
[ __ ] up exactly and then like pause
look at his weight look at his hips
right there this is over blah blah blah
and the people who are obsessed with it
not only will they enjoy watching it
they're also going to look at you as
like an expert in the field like whoa
this guy really understands the analysis
of MMA yeah cool makes you an expert if
I'm not an expert now then that's just
crazy
but to the average person right like
that doesn't know anything about
fighting right sometimes they look at us
and they look at it like a scrap yeah
they go oh wow yeah oh he grabbed him
and then he threw him and he hit him on
the ground I know they don't see the
chest in it
and I only know this coming from boxing
because I'm like I grew up as like a
huge boxman fan my dad used to cover
boxing like he used to you go to Ali's
camp and interview him and [ __ ] like
that so I'm like generational boxing fan
yeah so I'd watch [ __ ] I'd watch
people [ __ ] on May weather and I'd go oh
you don't understand you're watching the
greatest boxer ever yeah you don't
understand like like I remember watching
Mayweather are Mosley and seeing
Mayweather counter a Mosley jab and then
not seeing Mosey throw a jab again and
then going you don't realize he just
removed half of his body yeah he he he's
terrified to throw a jab because of what
he just did so to me watching somebody
break that down an expert that'd be
awesome yeah yeah that's good insight
for me I'm really curious who's like
your favorite guy to watch like who's
like this technical fighter you're like
bro I just love watching this dude damn
there's so many good guys man I
literally watch all the fights yeah even
like the newcomers I watch these guys I
watched The Dana White Contender series
because there's things that these
younger guys are doing that's like
that's interesting I wonder like how I
can Implement that into my own game this
is great this is really great yeah but
people think I got here by accident I'm
like dude I'm I'm literally a student of
the game like this is all I do even
people only know what you show them yeah
and if you don't show them these things
like the first John fight exactly yeah
that's all they know and then you showed
them the second one even myself I
remember watching a second I was like oh
holy [ __ ] this guy's kind of doing
whatever he wants yeah
it's a different you think it's like
who's the other guy that I just fought
last year and who the [ __ ] is this guy
you know but continue on the student in
the game like so who are the other
people that you're watching where you're
like wow this is really Connor Max
Holloway
um what about Conor you thought was so
special his counters yeah his counters
his kicks but he doesn't kick as much as
he used to yeah and um he will use these
great faints and the distance management
sometimes he'll do this awkward thing
where he'll leave a handout it kind of
like lulls you to sleep yeah but it
distracts the eyes because now you have
to pay attention it's not a traditional
stance this hand is now here it's here
you don't know if it's going to shoot up
an uppercut or he's going to shoot a
straight jab or he might go down yeah
and come with a big right hook faster so
it's like things like that that people
don't really pinpoint and go you got to
be careful when you're in there with him
because if you don't pay attention to
that that could be your ass on the
canvas staring up at the light see that
breaking down like because sometimes you
see Conor in that almost like karate
stance it's a really wide stance yeah
but that's really true if you have this
tight stance right here you're giving me
one thing to look at yeah and know
exactly where it's coming from now look
okay I kind of when he did that to
khabib in that first round khabib had a
you're looking for his eyes he was like
all right what the [ __ ] is going on when
kind of came out long he had his other
hand behind him and he's crouching and
crouching on him and he's closing the
Gap and I'm like khabib is backing up
retracting about to hit the damn cage
and like why the [ __ ] is could be
backing up [ __ ] go for it and take
this guy down but you see that kind of
gives him that illusion like maybe he is
as
where he say he what he says he is kind
of thing you know so you got to be a
little bit cognizant of what's actually
going on you can't just run in because
then you get clapped khabib could have
just shot him right there and got caught
the same way he did to Jose Aldo
um Jose Aldo got emotional through a big
strike open himself up and kind of
waited for it knew that that was what he
was going to do right down the pipe boom
something short left it's crazy yeah so
you got the like just seeing khabib like
being like taking a different approach
like okay I'm not gonna run run and push
him backwards like I normally do to
everybody else because khabibi just goes
forward yep so with kind of coming out
like that he respected the distance was
like okay I got to use a different
approach to come in he probably would
break it down a little bit different but
that's the way I'm analyzing it based on
all his other fights because I don't
know him like I love this yeah
you have to like I'm understanding a
fight in a way that I did not see yeah
like especially breaking down what's
Max's superpower
volume man and then he'll he'll throw
these Fates with his with his uh his
kicks or he'll lift his knee and then
you bite on a reaction get a reaction
and then from there he just starts
pissed like just piecing you up and he's
like you just hit me with a street
fighter 20 punches
like how is that even possible yeah yeah
and he's behind you and then he's
talking to DC he's like I'm the best
boxer in the UFC well he's slipping
punches in the [ __ ] Matrix like yeah
that's that's like [ __ ] that you just
don't that's unheard of that's like
superhero [ __ ] you know wow and
excluding you from the combo who's the
greatest fighter past or present I I
don't look at myself as the greatest
fighter but really yeah no I don't
um I'm a little different the way I
think about the game you know if people
want to say that that's cool but that's
not what how I
people probably say you should probably
see yourself as that but that's just
arrogance you know I think it's a I'm a
little bit different I can I see my
flaws I see my vulnerabilities and
things like that but the greatest
fighter right now like actively fighting
sure
God damn there's so many good guys I
mean I would throw Izzy in that
conversation yeah but then I also throw
Marcus having that conversation just
based on what he did like three weeks
ago yeah the guy has like there's really
no no flaws after doing what he just did
to
um Oliveira who was like Steam not
steamrolling but finishing guys he was
steamrolling dude but he would get
dropped you know getting dropped helps
him for some reason it's just amazing
yeah but he got dropped this time and it
was just like yeah I'm not taking my
foot off the gas though my foot is on
your neck yeah you know so it was a
little bit different but that's why I
said I'm like you could steamroll guys
and have no adversity but then he's
beating guys and putting them away but
he has like okay there's a little bit of
a roadblock you gotta get through that
and then once it gets through that
somehow he just puts these guys away
yeah would you put khabib in that combo
over like at the whole uh promotion
because he does whatever the [ __ ] he
wants to do yeah yeah there's one guy
who went the distance with him Al right
on a short notice 24 hours remember
people don't give out Credit Go could be
was just playing with him because he
wanted more cage time I was like dude we
don't get paid by the minute bro we
don't get paid by the second if he could
have gotten out of there he would have
gone and that's my teammate of course
why do you think I was so successful
wrestling background wrestling
background interesting and just not
being a [ __ ] he's a tough mother dude
Al is borderline
certified like that dude is like his his
mindset when he gets like locked into
something you can't that guy's like a
freight train with the the brakes were
broken like that guy's not gonna stop
wow until he gets what he wants that's
just his mentality but all his injuries
the knees
both surgeries and all that they [ __ ]
him up you know so for him to go from
fighting a striker a three-round fight
to go to a five round fight on 24 hours
notice no game plan no nothing just like
just fighting on basically what you know
he should have gotten tired in that
third round and possibly got finished
but he's survived the entire 25 minutes
and from there you could probably say oh
after a certain point I just didn't want
to hurt him anymore he could probably
say something like that but let's be
honest if you could have gotten him out
of there you would have gotten him out
of there yeah Al got up Al escaped
um multiple times not just like one time
like multiple times so people that don't
want to give him credit I'm like dude
could like we do things a little bit
different here in New York man like we
got a special team and in the sense of
the skill set that the guys possess that
wrestling is a big equalizer man like
power it seems like a wrestling man you
got to know what you're doing it can't
just be oh I know how to wrestle and
take guys down like say you know oh I
could take you down but then what
you know what I mean like I could take
you down he could go for it like like a
BJJ guy he could go for an arm bar he
could go for gifts capitalize on getting
it yeah he's like he's well-rounded you
know yeah I just wish we got to see more
of them without the injuries plaguing
them and uh because he's fun to watch
man that when he was in his prime that
guy was [ __ ] dudes up he's I think he
stuck like three guys in a row yeah just
like just knocking him out back to back
to back was like Yo dude you are a
certified record machine there's like
nobody that can stop this guy was he
that guy in the gym he was he was that
guy really Ray Ray made a spar one time
and we never sparred again why why is
that not the craziest [ __ ] thing I
don't know why I think it's because
we're so competitive this is my theory
yeah we're so competitive he was just
like I don't think this is good these
guys
they're gonna kill each other yeah yeah
we never spoiled after that we always
rolled or wrestled but when Alice bars
it's like the fight like watching him
was like where's where's my like there's
no 80 take my money no 80 I would have
watched him like dude kill him like that
yeah and he's just like whoa which bar
wow I don't spoil like that though I'm a
little bit nicer I was a little bit like
we're going to work yeah did did he have
a lot of respect for you though you
think you guys have a good relationship
I would think so yeah I hope so I hope
so
I forgot to ask this question to a few
of the other Fighters here how does the
people in UFC feel about Anderson Silva
losing oh how are we not even talking
about
I mean he's 47.
so he's like but he wasn't 47 before
when everybody was like why don't you
fight someone like Anderson Silva yeah
that's true but I'm saying he's 47 and
says that I thought he put up a great
fight oh
bro being 39 and like working out and
being sore the next day I can't imagine
being 47 and getting in there competing
at that level it looked a little bit
slower I mean not the same minutes of
silver that was in The Matrix fighting
Forrest Griffin fighting all these other
guys Rich Franklin yeah and making it
look easy yeah yeah like if it was back
then it's a different fight yeah I think
he finishes him we just had something to
come in uh Al Jermaine's humble Mr
greatest MMA journalist of all time oh
you might be the greatest you might be
number one I'm number one but he's
number one
number one honestly
are we live you spell my name wrong but
listen I'm 9.99 spelled that [ __ ]
however
no but real talk like yeah I think he
breaks down into a way that it's like
yeah there's a lot of stuff happens
before it happens I know I'm harping on
that but like before someone can
uh execute the takedown there's a lot of
like balance things that are happening
to even know that you can do that right
yes and I think the average person has
no [ __ ] clue what's happening until
someone just gets dropped on their back
yeah and and then the commentators are
saying it live and yeah of course we're
there we're locked in but sometimes
you're at a [ __ ] party you're talking
to your friends you're only listening
when some guy gets you know you hear
that the booth go crazy so it is really
cool to have it go back and then see and
exactly and even the commentators during
the fight they're not breaking it down
like that yeah they're not going oh here
he's going for the key Locker yeah yeah
like they're not breaking a thousand way
that it's like ah his uh body position
on this thing is is what caused that
move to happen so it's like that or this
is the mistake and even what happens to
you like for example like let's say you
get caught or you get put down you're
like I was going for this I lift my left
leg and this [ __ ] went for it
and that's what I thought yeah well cool
to see man even even the first John
fight like despite getting other
fighters to do it with you now we're
pitching you TV shows
you call up the homie and be like yo
listen let's go over your fight and he
goes oh yeah I see here I lifted my hip
right here he got under and you're like
why'd you do that well I was going for
this and you go oh I see why you could
do that that'd be cool to see you guys
geek out on that I don't know if many
fighters will like could humble
themselves to do that though but the
good ones yep that would be cool the
good ones of all I don't know from my
experience they're all reflective
they're all home yeah
respect the sport yeah otherwise like
even TJ like dude you lost and you're
still making these [ __ ] excuses and
driving me nuts yeah like dude shut the
[ __ ] up you had two blown out shoulders
it worked for you one time it didn't
work out this time I had a blown out
stroller I won seven fights in a row
yeah and then I got the surgery I got to
the UFC after one more fight like it
happens yeah don't you fought with one
leg okay you won but now all of a sudden
if he lost they'd be like oh it's
because the leg in the first round dude
shut the [ __ ] up dude nobody nobody
gives a [ __ ] we all got excuses even the
young fight I was killing him in the
first round and then I started like just
flicking the jab and then he slips and
cracks me with a right hand and drops me
and I have like a flash knock down and
go oh [ __ ] we're in a fight like that's
really what I'm thinking of my In the
Heat of the Moment and like despite how
I felt the day of the fight whatever not
having the proper rehydration I I ate
like an idiot I didn't eat I barely ate
anything dollar pizzas yeah what was
that I would at least have carbs in my
body but I wish it was and it wasn't
that and uh whatever but I could look
back at myself and go these are the
mistakes I made even though I didn't
feel good I could have done these things
better maybe so my I had brain fog
because I was so exhausted but going
back and looking at him like this is
what I was thinking but at the same time
he was sharp and I wasn't yeah you know
and I could I can give that up I can
yeah no problem but then we had a
rematch [ __ ] do what I had to do
yeah go go go home okay so after
weighing until fight what is like what
are you consuming how much are you
hydrating like because I can't even
imagine how much you guys put on after
like what are you is it structured does
it eat whatever you want like yeah it is
structured so we got the ufcpi team the
nutrition team they help us out for this
last fight I had Charles he helped me
out a ton and um the proper fluids
making sure you get the right amount of
cars back in and he had like a timer on
everything so that's the first thing you
want to put the fluids back in people
want to in the beginning I would think I
need to eat right away but I'm like no
you're dehydrated you need to put fluids
back in your body your brain you need to
have all that like filled out and is it
like IV fluids or just all everything
technically can't do the IV anymore I
know this wow I know this [ __ ]
out there still probably doing that [ __ ]
I did it one time I didn't feel the
difference I was like I'd rather just
stuff my face like a fat [ __ ] yeah did
you hear the uh the story about uh
Pacquiao and De La Hoya no remember when
they fought no no but I don't remember
this I don't know the story there's uh
when they basically went to go touch
gloves I think roach was there like I
think the coaches I guess came as well
when their touch glass and he saw that
Kayla Hoy had all these ice cracks and
he goes eat them up early
he goes eat them up early yeah yeah he's
a he had a hard [ __ ] cut and he had
to rehydrate heavy get there
and Pacquiao jumped on that ass the only
thing with that is I don't know if
I feel like the ivy is supposed to Fast
Track the rehydration it's supposed to
so I don't know if that you got to be so
dehydrated that you're using an IV yeah
people do it anyway that was like we're
not supposed to no well before usada
came in people would use the IVs all the
time that was like a thing as soon as
I'm done I get back I put some fluid
back in but I sit down I eat and I put
the IV in it so that was like always a
thing no matter like how much you really
cut but I did it one time I didn't feel
a difference you know really so that's
why with that specific thing I'm like
maybe it's an old school mentality thing
of thinking like maybe you did the IV so
that means he's [ __ ] up it's more like
he he had a hard weight cut yeah that's
why he had to IV yeah that's what I
think they were saying that that's yeah
that yeah I could see that like take us
through it so it's like are you
consuming gallons and gallons of water
are you eating mad food like what you
got to be you got to be a little bit
strategic about it you can't be like
crazy and just want to eat everything
because that will [ __ ] up your entire
train of camp and that's what I said
like my first young fight I had a
phenomenal training camp and I was like
I'm gonna smoke this guy in the first
round and then the day of the fight you
[ __ ] that up that eight ten weeks like
it never even [ __ ] happened that's
what I'm saying like I never had like
what what do you guys do to get back in
shape the right way so everyone gets
like a different program but for the
most part you want to put the carbs back
in but fluids is always first so like
for the first hour it's really about flu
it's putting that in your body first and
then they give you like a bagel or
something you don't have to eat that you
can eat like real food like eggs
whatever
um pancakes whatever they have on their
fruits but you got 24 hours to pretty
much kind of just figure it out but for
me I could just go by the schedule that
they give me it's not the easiest thing
because sometimes you just want to stuff
your face with cookies and [ __ ] yeah I
got a sweet tooth so I go crazy as soon
as the fight's over like that's why I
get to 170 so fast
it's like my body knows okay the fight's
over [ __ ] like stop playing
games yeah like it's go time right now
and I can't shut it off like my my brain
this is like a big disconnect yeah yeah
it's like sugar sugar 100 yeah and it'll
just keep going I'm just like this stop
but I'm just
just keep stuffing my
[Laughter]
damn but yeah so like even at night I'll
eat like like last fight I had a steak
and then I woke up the next morning I
was like 148 pounds I was like I'm way
too late because I would eat like pasta
I'll go to a buffet and I'll get a
little bit of this I'll get a little bit
of that I get some rice I get pasta I
get chicken I get steak now I eat
everything I even get ice cream and
cookies you feel too light that's
interesting yeah
because you want to add the weight you
need I need the weight it's like I put
that weight on you
[ __ ] I didn't think about wake I thought
that it just adds on easily right after
the weigh-in that's a weird anxiety to
wake up and be too light yeah so that
was like 15 pounds overnight like that's
what I'm it's crazy I was like 153 maybe
that night wow
so by the way you weighed in at what so
I weighed in 135 on Friday yeah but
fight night when we checked that was
about 152 pounds you added 18 [ __ ]
that's is that the biggest change you've
ever added not the biggest that's
[ __ ] I mean the biggest was 154 but
it's like it's so close it's like maybe
another meal not a meal but maybe like a
20 pounds but a 69 water bottle which is
a pound they say uh holy they say that
like uh you know football athletes will
do this as well where like they'll be
able to tell how much they weigh by
walking around they don't even need to
be on a scale yeah oh I'm about like 243
or whatever is that you kind of you know
you kind of know exactly to the T like
yeah I feel like I'm around this way
because you just you kind of get used to
it I've done it so much so often since
high school wrestling like I just know
my body that's right because you're
cutting [ __ ] weight to high school
right now too and even back then I'm
like this is sick
it's actually it's actually so crazy I'm
like and I talked to the UFC staff about
this I go why don't we just do cake
sizes weigh-ins because then you give
each other let's say like before you
fight you step on the scale 30 minutes
you're fighting
yeah but you can't do that it'll change
the whole game why it'll change the
whole game not because because they
you're walking around at 170. then I'll
probably fighting at 160.
yeah which is
going to be healthier but what I think
is going to be more dangerous I think
what people will do is they'll still do
all that cut which is what they said but
then I go but you're gonna get your ass
kicked so [ __ ] bad oh cause you're
gonna be like either that I can't
[ __ ] cut this much weight because
there's no not enough time to rehydrate
I think but I think what happened is
people were dying this is a boxing issue
and I think it changed in boxing first
and then happened in MMA so it happened
this was a thing that boxers were doing
I think that's why they moved the
weigh-ins earlier because I think when
it was closer because if you look at
even like amateur [ __ ] like I remember
like when I when I weighed in for gloves
it was like three days before
hmm yeah you have to like make within
three pounds whatever I I did a smoker
or whatever when I was younger but I
think it was like one I don't know about
that but I'm not trying to fight nobody
I'll [ __ ] Alex up easily that's easy
that's easy mixed martial arts right now
white dude that's like okay that's
awesome you could get dwarfed
dwarfs
[Laughter]
but yeah that's I think that's what
they're scared because isn't it uh don't
you have more of a risk of brain injury
if you're more dehydrated when you're
getting yeah but I do think like even
like we've had Jiu Jitsu matches where
this is that same philosophy where
you'll compete but it's like half hour
after you wait in or an hour yeah so it
like minimizes the time for how much
weight you can actually cut because you
won't be able to compete the next match
exactly the first match of the day for
this is the fifth place it was like yeah
in theory like people are going to be
dumb but then they're gonna realize like
okay that did not go well so what do we
do to maintain our performance I think
that's what I think yeah but maybe it's
not going to happen I think the other
thing is uh you don't want everybody in
the arena ready to go and then a guy
doesn't weigh in there that's true too
bad but then what's the difference
between the 24 hours before versus it
can at least get another opponent throw
them in there like they can shake some
things but then they have to make weight
the other opponent yeah they do right
but then they usually take someone else
from the card
um well if everyone made weight then
it's like yeah no listen I think the
goal we all agree on which is why don't
people fight at a weight that's a little
bit closer to what they walk around yeah
and then not like kill themselves to
lose and that's just unfortunate but how
do you make sure that a car that's worth
100 million dollars ends up happening I
mean I'm not seeing any of that 100
million so I'm just like you know but
we're going to get you to the 100
million
what's up baby let's go we got to get
you to the point where non-mma dudes are
calling you out
inside
you said it you said it talk that [ __ ]
right now you said it okay aside what
you trying to do my boy oh my boy yeah
makes an opportunity you're hurt wow
what's up
the Long Island [ __ ] I was like yeah but
all right
in New York yeah you checked out yeah
you checked out
okay before we get out of here
um because we've gone longer than we
expected because you're uh you're a
[ __ ] rock star in my way you're
killing it man now you're killing it
um before we get out of here I just want
you to tell everybody where they can
watch your podcast where they can watch
all your stuff and where are you going
to give them that analysis that you were
just breaking down so we'll do the
analysis and everything on my YouTube um
this way is video format so that's going
to be Funkmaster MMA
um the actual thing that we're doing the
the media which we just started this
week for UFC 281 is going to be the
weekly scraps media that's what we're
building out but all my social media is
Funk Mass MMA so that's everything all
streaming platforms Spotify
um all that good stuff shout out Joe
Rogan he's a man yes sir
he's helping me he's blessed me with a
lot of knowledge too man just like
understanding the game so easy to go
again like I just like to learn from
people that are smarter than I am or
have done it you know so that's where
everyone can find the content I'm on the
Twitter I talk a lot of [ __ ] just know I
don't take it personal you can talk [ __ ]
to me I'm gonna throw it right back at
you yeah I like to have fun did you pay
the eight bucks you got the you got the
checks
he lost my boy Eli Elon
you calling me lies your little nickname
yeah y'all a boy
anyway bro thank you so much for coming
dude man congrats on everything man who
do you want next let's say right before
we leave who I want next I want to fight
sugar strong on Molly Mr sugar tits Mr
poodle Mr poodle nuts
um I'm like let me not call him that I
like Sean that's my guy I like do you
like that I [ __ ] with Sean is it is it
tough to fight someone you like no hell
no if it's like a brother like it's
someone that I train with and everything
yeah
he's ranked number two yeah no one's no
one's talking about my Rob let's talk
about morale let's talk about Mariah
he's like the dark horse that nobody
wants to say his name they're all just
saying and like everyone talks about
everybody else but morale because nobody
wants that smoke he's that nice he's
[ __ ] good man he's a [ __ ] hammer
and you said that you wouldn't fight him
and he said he wouldn't fight you
exactly you guys are just I probably go
up or he'd go down we'll figure it out
like we're not there yet I think about
him stop all that [ __ ] yeah I gotta stop
all that I'm friends and I'm not fine
it's different if you just train upon us
that's different but no we we hang out
we like this is like fan lock that
you fight and then you friends right
after that bro when you get smashed with
the elbow in your head it hits you
differently he's like oh this
[ __ ] trying to kill me yeah yeah
this is like could you be friends the
same way after like hypothetically if
you guys fought I don't know man I think
that energy is just always like we share
the moment but that energy is always
going to be different rightly because
like if you win or you lose you're still
gonna feel like
you're a little tight yeah how could you
not like but sometimes the ego is gone
when you at least when you get dominated
by somebody like if but that makes it
even worse really I really want to
[ __ ] yeah this [ __ ] I'm just
saying I want to see all the best fights
in the UFC and if that makes the best
fight I don't give a [ __ ] if y'all
friends I want to see nah
okay so everybody check out my app you
want sugar Shawn I want sugar Shawn I
love what he's doing with his podcast
and everything too he's the man same
thing like just building out his brain
he's done a [ __ ] unbelievable job
smartest self-promotion yes and he's
built himself up to be a star and that's
why he's gonna get the money that star
deserve 100 and that's what a lot of I
mean you already know this but a lot of
Fighters need to do that it's like you
have the platform which the UFC what are
you doing outside of that to build
yourself up what type of connections are
you but I know what you are yeah but
other guys have to be doing that [ __ ]
they got to be on Twitter they got to be
on Instagram because the bigger you are
over there the more money you're gonna
make over here but a lot of these
athletes don't want to do that so it's
just like
you know so it's like dude you got to
help me out a little bit so I can help
you yeah at the end of the day this puts
money in your pocket 100 well anyway
anything you need I mean that sincerely
you let us know I appreciate that yeah
this is dope brother I just want to say
one thing I don't want to see is that
dancing Giver again wait
I can't help you with it for real if you
want to go play that song
[Music]
[Applause]
hey hey